el momento en france 24 de conocer las
principales noticias en materia
económica y por eso nos acompaña por
supuesto nuestra compañera daniela
blandón y vamos a comenzar en venezuela
no que vendió una refinería de república
dominicana verdad dan y así de santiago
primero recordemos que en la refinería
dominicana de petróleo refidomsa el
gobierno de ese país tenía el 51 por
ciento de participación y venezuela
tenía el 49 por ciento ahora a través de
una operación de canje de deuda la
administración de nicolás maduró cedió
sus acciones por 88 millones de dólares
al ejecutivo dominicano que ahora tendrá
el 100 por ciento el gobierno de nicolás
maduro dice que con esto paga parte de
su deuda externa ya que las medidas
impuestas por eeuu que califica de
delictivas no le han permitido cumplir
con sus obligaciones financieras el
valor de la transacción no es ni
siquiera un 1 por ciento de los 150 mil
millones de dólares que analistas y
agencias especializadas como la afp
calculan que estarían las obligaciones
de venezuela en divisas esto también
aclararlo y la oposición también criticó
esta transacción porque la porción que
tenía venezuela en esta refinería
terminó vendiéndose casi 50 millones de
dólares menos de los 135 que costó hace
más de una década y permanecemos un
momento más en la región aquí en américa
latina brasil y argentina están
negociando lo que sería la construcción
nunca producto verdad sí señor el
anuncio lo hizo el presidente brasil de
brasilia ir bolsonaro quien dijo que su
país busca acceder al gas de esquisto
del prolífero yacimiento vaca muerta que
está localizado en la provincia
argentina de neuquén
argentina ha propuesto que el gasoducto
recorra a cerca de 1500 kilómetros hasta
la frontera en uruguayana y otros 600
kilómetros desde allí hasta porto
allegre para que se conecte con la red
brasileña y así ayudar a reducir el
precio local del gas el proyecto apenas
se está discutiendo pero se calcula que
constará cerca de 5 mil millones de
dólares 3 mil 700 millones para el
pedazo argentino y 1.200 millones para
el brasileño
hay uno que diría que son muy seguras no
pero hay un nuevo robo en plataformas de
cripto monedas no son tan seguras
santiago y por eso es que no están
tampoco avaladas por las autoridades
económicas
la japonesa liquid se convirtió en la
más reciente plataforma de cripto
monedas en ser atacada por hackers que
robaron 97 millones de dólares de las
billeteras virtuales de los clientes en
su cuenta de twitter esta empresa señaló
que está investigando el tema y que va a
proporcionar actualizaciones periódicas
al tiempo que suspende los depósitos y
retiros de cripto activos sólo en japón
ha habido varios grandes robos en esas
plataformas en los últimos años
el más reciente fue justamente la semana
pasada la plataforma de cifrado poli
network fue protagonista de un robo
cifrado por 610 millones de dólares uno
de los más grandes de este tipo en la
historia aunque después aseguró que los
hackers habían devuelto casi todo el
botín muy queridos sí la verdad muy
amables veníamos a perú del dólar batió
un nuevo récord
la moneda local peruana renovó su máximo
histórico el viernes tras apreciarse un
cero 27 hasta los 41 soles por cada
divisa
estadounidense el dólar ha tenido una
tendencia alcista en las últimas semanas
por dos motivos principales el repunte
global de la divisa y la incertidumbre
de los inversionistas ante la coyuntura
política semanas después de que el
izquierdista pedro castillo asumiera la
presidencia ahora una explicación corta
cuando en una economía los
inversionistas están nerviosos se llevan
sus dólares y al haber menos oferta de
divisas circulando pues el precio tiende
a subir claro daríamos a eeuu las deudas
estudiantiles así son un problema para
muchísimas personas y el gobierno
estaría aprendiendo con donar algunas
claro el gobierno federal hoy ofrece un
alivio de deuda para aquellos
estudiantes que esté en total y
permanentemente discapacitados y que
tengan ingresos limitados pero para
acceder a ellos tienen que someterse a
complejos requisitos como por ejemplo
tres años de vigilancia para comprobar
su condición el secretario de educación
miguel cardona anunció que de aquí a
final de año se borrará automáticamente
esa deuda de las cuentas de al menos 323
mil estudiantes y recalcó que se está él
y nando una barrera que impidió que
muchos prestatarios recibieran estas
extensiones a las que tienen derecho por
ley se calcula que para eso tendrá que
asignar unos 5 mil 800 millones de
dólares
veremos cómo avanza cerramos con la
cifra del día como siempre
455 millones de euros por este valor el
fcbarcelona logró un crédito a través de
una operación dirigida por command sachs
en la que participaron varios
inversionistas para tratar pues de
superar esta crisis económica han ido a
blandón completísima crónica económica
en esta audiencia limitamos como siempre
a continuar informarnos en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com
[Música]